okay you right-wing maniacs religious
zealots conspiracy theorists and other
decent good americans and worldwide
citizens i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it is
monday january 24th in the year 20
22 and we are live streaming of course
on rumble.com on youtube and on blaze tv
please do me a favor make sure that
you're subscribed wherever you watch and
you can share you can tap notification
bells
and the rest of it we once again are in
our temporary studio here which we're
making some adjustments on things are
coming together i know there were some
audio issues last week i think
everything's going to start shaking out
this week
and most importantly all of my stuff
from los angeles i'm being told is on a
truck right now and it's getting here so
i won't have to sit on an ikea chair
which is what i did all weekend i just
sat on one ikea chair and i ate from one
ikea plate and i drank from one ikea
glass so i'm very excited we got a great
show for you today especially this first
segment where i really want to do a deep
dive on something that's been driving me
crazy we're going to be covering a bit
of what happened on real time with bill
maher on friday night you guys know my
feelings about bill maher i think he's
one of the last good decent liberals but
he seems to be unable to get to the
conclusion which is that you cannot be a
democrat i always say you don't have to
be a republican but you cannot be a
democrat he had barry weiss on barry
weiss is sort of in that half liberal
kind of thing and basically she just
said a bunch of stuff related to covid
that all of us have been saying for
about two years pretty much every
conservative insane person has been
saying for two years
but then when she said it oh lockdowns
aren't good we're causing kids to have
depression etc the the internet over the
weekend went bananas and it was like oh
a liberal finally said something sane
and this leads me to my my struggle with
this issue and i'm sort of friendly with
barry so it's it makes it doubly
compounding so i want to dive into a
whole bunch of things we've got a whole
bunch of video clips for you on that uh
then
our uh our immigration secretary is
basically saying hey we're not going to
arrest you if you're here illegally
that's a problem uh finally oh no then
two more cnn have you heard of this
network really terrible place bunch of
crazy people on there just lies more
more lies
we'll get to that and then the joe biden
guy that uh you know they put out out
there every now and again to say a bunch
of stuff and read poorly off the
teleprompter and the rest of it his
approval is plummeting and he's got a
whole bunch of other
problems before i get to any of that i
just thought i would tell you one quick
story in 30 seconds which is i had some
friends in town uh last night friends
from los angeles who are considering
moving here like everybody else
and we're sitting there
had a little tequila we're chatting
about life and it's like they're here in
florida they've been here for a couple
days like they're smiling they're happy
got a little sun like feeling good about
everything realized just about the
energy here and the business and the
opportunity all of that stuff
and my friend she's going on and on
about how horrible it is there and the
crime in los angeles and they're hearing
gunshots for the first time she shows me
a picture literally of a needle sitting
right side or outside of her office her
office which is on a pretty decent
street um and they're going on and on
about the problems there and i'm looking
at my two friends it's a married couple
i'm looking at two of them i'm like
all right are you guys crazy like just
get going just get going and that is my
message to all of you that are in these
crazy places get going we want you here
in the good places to help us build and
help us fight so otherwise it's just
like you're crazy people you're crazy
people who live around crazy people and
until you leave the craziness the
craziness is part of your life but it
ain't part of my life because i live
here in florida all right let's talk
about convention estates and then get to
all the stories guys uh president joe
biden is ruining our country
it's true there's really no other way to
say it he's destroyed the economy he's
embarrassed us on the world stage he's
failed to promise to his he's failed in
his promise to end covid and now he's
working to federalize all elections the
question for us is what are we going to
do about it you know that i don't like
empty talk i don't like political games
i like real solutions i like people who
do things and that's exactly what i
found in the convention of states
project led by my friend mark meckler a
great guy the convention of states
project is seeking to call an article 5
convention of states at this convention
the states gather to propose
constitutional amendments that limit
federal power and yes that includes the
power of our wonderful president joe
biden i'm not alone in supporting the
call for this convention glenn beck
governor ron desantis and mark levin
have all voiced their support for this
initiative and you can too go to
conventionofstates.com today and sign
the petition to demand that your state
legislators vote yes to convention of
states convention of states legislation
is pending across the country stop
complaining and do something visit
convention estates.com and sign the
petition today again that's
conventionofstates.com
dave and now back to me and by the way i
think in uh october if i'm not mistaken
i'll be speaking at a convention of
states convention
which will be here in orlando in the yes
free state of florida okay so let's talk
about uh bill maher and barry white so
you all know who bill maher is of course
he has been the standard bearer of
liberalism of leftism in america for
probably about 30 years right he was a
big comic in the 80s then he got the
show politically incorrect which was a
precursor to real time you may remember
that politically incorrect was actually
canceled it was an early cancel culture
victim it was cancelled because right
after 9 11 bill maher went on television
it was on abc at the time and he went on
and basically said hey you can say a lot
of things about these jihadists these
people who flew planes into these
buildings but you can't say that they
aren't brave because look at what they
did now of course that was misconstrued
and maybe he used language in a bit of a
sloppy way and everything else but the
show in essence was cancelled a few
months later so he's he's been around
the block
and you guys know bill maher has been
great against wokism he has been great
against identity politics he has been
great when it comes to talking about
free speech all of these things
however he does always call all
republicans racist
donald trump's a nazi
he still loves all the big government
stuff but he's kind of getting there and
i basically like the guy and i want him
to get there i know a little something
about the adventure of a liberal
actually waking up actually being
red-pilled and getting to the end of the
road right
now another person you can put in that
bucket is barry weiss barry weiss of
course was a columnist at the new york
times and she she actually wrote the
original piece about the intellectual
dark web which was about me and jordan
peterson and the weinsteins and sam
harris and everybody else that sort of
blew up the whole thing i'll get to that
more in just a second but about two
years ago barry weiss left the new york
times because she could not deal with
the wokeness the identity politics stuff
she felt it was it was an intolerable
place to work so i i hold her in high
regard in that sense now she was on real
time
this past friday talking about covid and
i think what you're going to see is
she's going to make a whole hell of a
lot of sense
well you decide no i'm done with covey
i'm done it's like i i went so hard on
kovid i yeah i remember braid the
pringles cans that i bought at the
grocery store stripped my clothes off
because i thought kovit would be on my
clothes like i did it all i watched
tiger king i got to the end of spotify
like
we all did it right
and no no we didn't all do it well
here's the thing a lot
a lot of us did do it and then we were
told you get the vaccine you get the
vaccine and you get back to normal
and
we haven't gotten back to normal and
it's ridiculous at this point
i know that so many of my liberal and
progressive friends are with me on this
and they do not want to say it out loud
because they are scared to be called
anti-vaxx or to be called science denial
or to be you know smeared as a trumper
i'm sorry if you believe the science you
will look at the data that we did not
have two years ago and you will find out
that cloth masks do not do anything you
will realize that you can show your
vaccine passport at a restaurant and
still be asymptomatic in carrying
omicron and you will realize most
importantly that this is going to be
remembered by the younger generation as
a catastrophic moral crime
the city of flint michigan which is 80
percent i think minority students has
just announced indefinite virtual
schooling in the past two years we've
seen among young girls a 51 increase in
self-harm people are killing themselves
they are anxious they are depressed they
are lonely
that is why we need to end it more than
any inconvenience that it's been to the
rest of us i think
okay
it's like at this point
it's a pandemic of bureaucracy
okay so there's a lot there so first off
i just want to say i'm sort of friendly
with barry she has been to my house
multiple times for dinner she's been
over for parties we've gone out okay i
don't think she is a bad person and
obviously what she's saying there is
right
but here's the problem
there's a whole bunch of us and i'm not
making this about me there's a gajillion
people out there that have been saying
this all along now most of those people
happen to be scary conservatives that
were anti-lockdown and
anti-mandate and all of those things and
by the way as i've said many times i
grant everyone a long leash in that
first month if you were spraying your
pink pringle cans down and i was washing
an egg crate and all of the nonsense
that they had us doing that first month
it was just haywire and and i suppose
there were a few people who truly truly
saw what was happening right from the
beat but i'll grant everybody a long
leash for that first month now
everything that barry said there was
right about all that stuff and the
depression and all those things with
kids we talk about this on the show all
the time obviously now the problem is at
the end there well there's several
problems but at the end there the last
line she says this is a pandemic of
bureaucracy
except she's for the bureaucracy bill
maher is for the bureaucracy they love
democrats she's talking about what
they're doing in michigan to kids
okay michigan is run by gretchen whitmer
a democrat she is sitting next to
actually why don't we pull it up right
now the tweet uh the uh richie torres
thing so she's sitting next to while
she's talking the guy that i think you
see in the video there is a guy by the
name of richie torres who's a
congressman from new york who again i
think is probably a halfway decent
liberal he's not a complete nut bag but
here's his twitter profile he's got his
gender pronouns in there so this is what
liberals do with everything it's like
you guys create all of the problems and
then for the last two years as she
pointed out oh there are these good
progressives and liberals that don't
want to be called trumpers well she and
especially bill maher you guys have run
around calling the rest of us racist and
backwards and religious freaks and
zealots and all of those things so it's
like if you guys get everything wrong
for two years
right or you're always behind and then
you get it
roughly right
then what what is it that we do like if
you're if your conclusion is still okay
vote for democrats if your conclusion is
okay give more tax money to the
bureaucracy that you're attacking if
you're if you see the road and you take
the road
and you understand what's happening and
then there's the end of the road
and you just kind of look back and you
go well i can't get to the end of the
road because the end of the road is yes
these people gotta go and yes maybe
conservatives are conserving something
freedom which is what liberals are
supposed to want to conserve uh so you
can see that this is a little bit messy
here and the reason that it really kind
of got on my radar this weekend because
i've known about this i've been
frustrated about this sort of thing
obviously for quite some time but then i
saw a gazillion
conservatives applauding basically like
oh my god barry weiss isn't she amazing
and bill maher in real time it's so
incredible what they're doing because
they're saying something true because
finally a liberal doesn't seem like a
complete lunatic so even people that i
totally like so clay travis tweeted this
it was also shared by ted cruz i
consider both of these guys friends i
like them so this is not attacking them
in any way i'm bringing it up to to
point out the specific specific issue
here clay travis said on twitter the
most impressive thing about barry weiss
on last night's bill maher is the wild
applause after she finishes here after
two years the tides are turning even for
the left-leaning people in this country
when it comes to covid so of course
what clay is saying and what ted cruz
shared of course that's right and it's
good right we want to see
these lefties move right we want to see
these people wake up and this is one of
those airlock moments you may remember a
couple months ago when jon stewart went
on the colbert show and all of us for
about a year and a half were at least
somewhat talking about the possibility
that kovid was from the wuhan lab and
that it got leaked out right a whole
bunch of us were talking about it we
were all conspiracy theorists and i'm
sure we were somehow racist because of
that and the rest of it well then
suddenly the mainstream media felt oh
well jon stewart he's a good liberal and
he went on the show of a good liberal
and they talked about something so now
the mainstream media suddenly could talk
about it and it was suddenly on cnn and
washington post and everywhere else this
moment with weiss and mar is one of
those airlock moments it's like now
people are going to start talking about
it because they see the writing on the
wall right they see the polls
where democrats are going to get
absolutely slaughtered in the midterms
where three weeks ago during christmas
when everyone got coveted vaccinated or
not and it all became obvious that it
was all [ __ ] they see the writing on
the wall but again
that's good you want people to wake up
you want people to evolve been there
done that wrote a book about it i get it
that's what that's what being a
functioning human is all about like
getting new information living something
and then and then figuring out how you
want to move forward with it that's what
it's all about so you can see where the
conflict is here if at the end you're
still
for the democrats the people that are
locking you down if at the end you still
think all the conservatives who you run
around call racist and everything else
are wrong about everything then then
what is a good liberal at this point i
get it they're better than the woksters
there's no question about it okay get it
true absolutely
but at the end
if your conclusions are to vote for the
very things that you endlessly rail
against that are coming for your free
speech that are bringing in this
neo-racism that are locking you down and
all of those things just because you
spent so much time calling the other
guys racist
then perhaps
perhaps you need a mirror
maybe i'll send them a mirror can i can
i get all right amazon sells mirrors or
somewhere sells mirrors i think i have
to go back to ikea later i'm going to
send barry weiss and bill maher
a mirror i want to go a little little
further on this uh mike uh john cardillo
who's a great guy who i was uh i had
dinner with at the desantis event i was
at a couple weeks ago he had an
interesting tweet that then was uh tweet
retweeted by mike cernovich that i think
explains a little bit of this a little
bit further so john cardillo said this
country is about to make a hard right
turn the left has no idea what's coming
then mike cernovich who i've had on the
show a couple times i consider a friend
he retweeted and he said something that
i think gets to the heart of this he
says yes sir that's why the moderate
left democrat voters are trying to pace
and lead conservatives by pretending
they give a [ __ ] about the lives
destroyed by the woke left they aren't
needed and conservative simping for tv
man said good has to stop so you see
what he's saying there he's basically
saying so all these people who get it
wrong these these good
liberals right these good liberals
because they're not woke but they kind
of get it
and then they go on television and they
say something sane and then we all
applaud oh my god they're not all
completely bananas but it's actually a
problem because they would gladly throw
us under the bus when when the day comes
unless they're willing to make
that final that final step now the
reason i thought the cernovich tweet and
i know this maybe feels a little insider
baseball but i'm trying to paint a case
here okay uh the reason i thought the
cernovich tweet was interesting was
because if you remember and i'm sure
many of you do the original article
about the intellectual dark web that
barry wrote in the new york times that
that the wolksters tried to cancel her
for
she had a line in there that if you're
an interviewer and in this case she was
talking about me and joe rogan
specifically she said if you talk to
people like cernovich and she actually
used his name if you talk to people like
cernovich i think she also mentioned
alex jones
she said you'd have to be cynical or
stupid
and she repeatedly before the article
was public asked me to basically say i
regret doing my interview with cernevich
i've never interviewed alex jones so
that was the one she was really hung up
on i should just if i would just say
that i did something wrong that that
line wouldn't be in the in the piece
itself after the piece was published she
told me that the the publisher force or
the editor forced her to put it in but i
think it's i think you get the point
here so let's let's move uh forward a
little bit to now bill maher talking
about florida because i think again you
will see all right you got the ideas
right but are we going to get to the end
of the road are we going to get to that
that golden pot at the end of that
rainbow which is in florida take a look
florida like stayed open i mean i was
just in florida i've been there a few
times since this started half of new
york has moved there
the atmosphere is just different i'm not
moving to florida i'm not promoting
florida i'm just saying aoc just went to
florida and had a good time without a
mask
okay
i'm just saying i've been to florida the
atmosphere was just night and day from
california which was gloomy and
everything was the the andromeda strain
was out there and you went to fl
you went to florida
and i'm just saying yes there are
different factors in different states
but basically it's like they stayed open
and went on with life and they didn't do
a hell of a lot worse and maybe did
better
you know i just realized the way we do
this show my mic is cut obviously when
we're showing you a video clip right
there and basically i'm just screaming
and cursing at connor and michael about
what we're watching and then we come
back to me and then i somewhat cool off
but do you see what the problem is do
you get it people bill maher i'm not
moving to florida i'm not he has to
preface it by saying somehow florida is
bad i have been in florida for one month
florida is [ __ ] spectacular that
sorry about that i had to do it
it is spectacular i went to whole foods
yesterday i was mobbed by people every
single person welcome to florida we're
so happy you're here big smiles on their
face people wanted to buy me things at
whole foods you don't have to buy me
food
but so he has to preface it by saying
i'm not moving there because the
implication is florida's red and this
ron desantis guy is a bad dude he's a
mean man but then he also acknowledges
aoc vacations here swalwell vacations
here that [ __ ] gretten whitmer
i also had a lot of coffee this morning
she also vacations here they all get it
but they won't get to that so what what
do you mean and i truly i'm not
attacking you personally vilmar and i
would enjoy and hope that we will have a
conversation one day i really do
but what is it that you really mean i'm
not moving there somehow i'm better i'm
still a good california liberal even
though we've got the andromeda strain
here and everyone's got their heads
wrapped in plastic bags and no one goes
out and it's depressing and there's
crack needles or whatever you do with
crack they don't do pipes they're pipes
i guess
so what are you people actually saying
and then barry's like oh yeah yeah yeah
then all the new york people they've
moved down to florida too
so what is it that you guys are saying
so so the question if you want to get to
the question
the question
ron desantis do you support him yes or
no barry weiss
do you support him yes or no you know
what's right here you know it's wrong
you live in los angeles just like bill
maher you know how [ __ ] up that place
is sorry one more time that's it i won't
do it again right you get it
okay
so would you support ron desantis how
about how about glenn younkin i
mentioned this a couple weeks ago so you
guys you're the good liberals right
you're the good liberals we're against
woke-ism we don't want critical race
theory in schools we don't want to teach
neo-racism okay great you talk about it
all the time did you publicly say
whether you would have supported glenn
yunken or not bill maher did you say
after the election that that's really
great that that republican won because
otherwise another democrat was going to
win and it was going to get much worse
for the kids in school who are being
taught that they're racist and locked
down and put in masks and then to
barry's point they're all going to be
even more depressed
i built a case here guys
i feel like i did i've been trying to
get this off my chest in the right way
for quite some time so i think for the
rest of us right so for you watching
this for any of us that have roughly got
stuff right that that we want these
people to get the right ideas right so
that's the takeaway here i want these
people to wake up but at some point if
you get everything wrong you tell people
to vote the wrong way and then two years
later
you just say the same [ __ ] that everyone
else has been saying and then all of us
we applaud you for it it's so great
it's a real problem it's a real problem
so i guess really the question then is
what makes these people
liberals anymore
what makes them leftists anymore and
what makes them democrats more than
anything else okay what really is it and
i and it always comes down to two things
it seems to me
it comes down to abortion they love
abortion lefties love abortion i don't
want to get into the whole abortion
thing at the moment okay they love
abortion that's a big one and then it's
the religion thing
and for bill maher who's been the you
know i'm the biggest atheist and
religious people are all morons and
backwards and you know praying to their
sky spaghetti god and everything else he
has i don't know how he digs himself out
of that hole right like he's gone so
deep on that to say oh my god it turned
out that the religious people and the
conservative people have called racist
and stupid all these years like how do i
actually kind of have that maya culpa
and go oh maybe you guys kind of did
know something maybe there were some
time-tested ideas that i should have
maybe paid a little more attention to or
there's a reason you're all not bananas
or you do see the truth before we do or
something like that i don't know how he
does that as for barry as far as i know
she's a somewhat conservative jew so i
suppose she's more okay with the
religious part of it but it's religion
and abortion because the other stuff
like
at this point do you think big
government programs are good do you
think affirmative action is good do you
think giving money to poor people to
keep them in cycles of poverty is good
so i don't think they're stupid i don't
think bill maher or barry or these five
remaining good liberals are stupid so
it's like if you if you don't think that
stuff then it comes down to abortion and
religion and it's like get there guys
what can i do this is my message to you
guys and i said i suppose this should be
the message for any of you watching this
to any of your
non-insane liberal friends if you get it
if you're getting it now if you're
getting how badly the democrats and the
leftists destroyed so much of the
country and the cities and everything
else it does not mean you have to be a
republican but let's get you over there
let's get you over the hump otherwise
is this good or bad what bill maher and
barry weiss are doing if they get
everything right but then at the end
it's like okay
maybe you shouldn't have you know helped
destroy donald trump because things
would be a lot better right now
obviously if donald trump was president
right or if ron desantis becomes
president or any republican becomes
president but so if at the end you're
always going to do the wrong thing then
is this net good or bad it's like yeah
it's nice that you're not completely
insane i guess that's what it is it's
like i should send them a mirror and
then also we could probably we can have
one custom-made i think you can get
those little trophies custom-made and
it's like congrats you're not completely
bananas and you can put it on your
mantel like that would be that
segment one everybody can i get a round
of applause here or something yeah can i
a little passion guys
cheering
what
all right
let's continue and i'll talk more about
crazy democrats and you tell me
if this guy secretary department of
homeland
security secretary alejandro mayorkas
you tell me if this is the guy that
should be in charge of illegal
immigration or not we've got videotape
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action
can we play that again because he
couldn't have possibly i mean he's a
democrat these are good people
lawful people people with good ideas he
couldn't the guy in charge of
immigration couldn't have
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement act wait sorry maybe my ear
thing is not right today let me get this
in
that can't be i couldn't maybe i didn't
hear one more time unlawful presence in
the united states will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action did you get that did
you get that this is the guy in charge
of the border and he is basically saying
if you can figure out a way to get in
we ain't gonna boot you possibly not do
anything and maybe we'll even give you
some money uh if you figure out a way to
get in we're not going to put you how
insane is that let me read the quote one
more time unlawful presence in the
united states will alone not be a basis
for immigration enforcement action
so to link this to the previous segment
for just one second bill maher barry
weiss you want to prove me wrong you
want to show me you're getting to the
end of the road
tweet about this today i dare ya i'll
retweet you tweet about this today that
this ridiculous buffoon in the oval
office appointed this guy mayorkus to be
in charge of our borders and now we are
literally saying if you are here
illegally
but you don't do anything bad we just
ain't gonna do anything about it that's
not how a country is run dare i quote
that orange guy who said without borders
you don't have a country well that's
pretty much where we're at at this point
so again
what is it that democrats are doing that
is good what is it that these liberals
are doing they don't believe
that if you are here illegally that is
your break in the law right right then
and there and by the way there's nothing
anti-immigrant about this and there is
nothing racist about this or anything
else nations have borders that's how it
works every nation on earth has borders
what they do in those borders is up to
them i personally
would prefer not to live in a country
where the people in charge said oh if
you can just come here you can have all
of our stuff and all of the benefits and
by the way we'll let you vote right
these idiots in new york city they're
letting illegal immigrants vote you
think they might vote for more
government programs for them which will
take more from the legally tax-paying
citizens i mean do you see how the whole
game works man
these people are insane so
what do we do what do we do well why why
would it be that people would be insane
right like why would it so what what's
going on in their mind give the devil is
due so when when maorkis says this in
his mind he's saying well we want to be
somewhat nice to these people right like
some people got here one way or another
and maybe they had kids here and by the
way there are plenty of people who got
here illegally who end up being really
good citizens and get educations and
start businesses and work real hard and
all of those things so i'm not even
against any of those people as
individual human beings it's just simply
does a system work or not do police
actually do policing do border agents
actually guard the border just like
anything else right like do you just let
anyone walk into your house and if you
happen to walk outside to pick up the
newspaper and the door is open so
someone walks in and creates a camp in
your living room do you just let them
stay
but for some reason we do this odd thing
with our country so we really need to
think seriously about getting rid of the
democrats i'm sorry that's what it all
comes down to at this point and it ain't
because the republicans are so great but
they're not bat [ __ ] looney
speaking about [ __ ] looney great segway
dave uh cnn have you seen this channel
they've got this stelter guy the potato
man and he's got now his sidekick oliver
darcy who i think sort of used to be a
conservative and then he went the other
way which these people like what's the
deal what's the deal with that uh well
they had a guest on who just made even
less sense than what you'd usually find
on cnn but that's that's the goal right
the goal of this kind of coverage is to
freak people out to cause them to live
in fear ironically a lot of the
fear-mongering is about the things that
are not actually mortal threats and then
there's ignoring the things that are
mortal threats you know covet isn't real
and climate change isn't real i would
argue that to me anyway those things are
a little bit scarier or have been
scarier at various points in the past
couple of years and instead it's about
the immigrant hordes and the senile
president and critical race theory
brainwashing your kids and and things
that are you know
if if not
just exaggerated invented out of whole
cloth
oh right that's right critical race
theory being taught in school you all
know this is happening all over the
place it's exactly why glenn younkin won
in virginia yes they try to get you on
some definition of critical race theory
that it's not exactly what's taught but
we are we know they're dividing classes
by race they're making it easier for
certain students based on skin color or
gender or whatever to get into certain
clubs or to play different sports all
you know all of the stuff so she's
saying okay it's just invented out of
whole cloth it's either exaggerated or
invented out of whole cloth also biden's
cognitive decline it's like uh that is a
problem that is a problem you know
there's this putin guy and he's not this
really great guy he may want to do some
bad stuff in the world and putin he may
want to invade ukraine it seems like
it's going to happen now i don't know
what we're supposed to do i don't
personally i don't think we should do
anything probably like it just kind of
sucks but i don't think we have the
wherewithal as a country to really do
anything at the moment but do you think
that putin is afraid of joe biden who
obviously has severe cognitive decline
and to link this to our previous story
as well it's like that's one of the
things we don't talk about but suddenly
when one of the good liberals either jon
stewart or bill maher or somebody will
talk about biden's cognitive decline
publicly well then suddenly everyone
will be talking about it and all of us
crazy right-wing conservatives they'll
go oh well you guys were still racists
and conspiracy theorists and everything
else but you know now we're gonna just
say the thing that you've been saying
for
uh two years so what's interesting about
this is it shows it it's just one of
those things where
it shows you the layer being peeled off
these people they lie about all of these
things right they lie about critical
race theory in school they lie about
biden's cognitive decline you know all
the stuff about you know brett kavanaugh
is a serial rapist the covington kids
are all racist donald trump very fine
people like you know all they lie about
absolutely everything
but
when something pops up
that is somewhat true like critical race
theory and schools and some of this
other stuff woke-ism all of the nonsense
that's exaggerated or invented out of
whole clock like you see the difference
there when we lie it's we're lying for
the greater good or something like that
and that's a little bit different but
this brings us into the fourth story uh
which is all about that joe bide and
there was some really interesting uh
video from
biden's press conference a couple days
ago i think it was on thursday or friday
if i'm not mistaken been very busy over
here uh where a newsmax reporter i think
it's james rosen uh i believe it was
james rosen yeah we'll see in just a sec
he actually
commented on biden's cognitive decline
yes
thank you very much for this honor james
rosen with newsmax i'd like to
i'd like to raise a delicate
subject but with utmost respect for your
life accomplishments and the high office
you hold
a
poll released this morning
by politico morning consult
found
49 percent of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement
joe biden is mentally fit
not even a majority of democrats who
responded
uh strongly affirmed that statement
i'll let you all make the judgment
whether they're correct well so the
question i have for you sir if you'd let
me finish
is why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
that was it i have no idea and then he
mumbled something a little bit earlier
before that now look i don't want to
make
light of cognitive decline i don't want
to make light of dementia or alzheimer's
or any of that stuff i've told you guys
many times i spent a lot of time with my
grandma elaine who i absolutely adored
and loved and laughed with more than
anyone else on this earth
when she developed dementia in her last
couple years and a lot of repetition and
frustration
and then some good times happen too
because you forget some some of the pain
in life and she sort of became who she
was supposed to be at the end
but i'm not diminishing any of the
horror related to any of that because it
will affect everyone one way or another
well whether it affects you personally
or someone in your family or friends or
anything that being said joe biden is
purportedly the president of the united
states he's supposed to be in charge
he's supposed to be the guy with the
finger on the button he's supposed to be
the guy that is the pilot of the plane
the captain of the ship
50 percent basically half of the people
in the country do not believe he's right
so whether
he has dementia or just old person
syndrome or something else or it's just
that he's old and there's a lot of
freaking pressure on him and suddenly
his stutter is coming back that's what
they're sort of telling us like whatever
it is if half the people think that
there is something truly wrong with you
and we all know about the mumbling and
the confusion and forgetting people's
names and everything else it's like
whatever the truth is whatever
specifically the truth is
related to a diagnosis or whatever it's
like that's actually secondary to
there's a legitimacy problem
even with democrats but note that was a
newsmax reporter it's not talked about
on nbc it's not talked about
on
you know cnn or read about in the new
york times watching post or anything
but it will be
right and when it will be then they'll
all go oh we all knew we all knew and
then you're going to watch people in the
administration and they're going to go
well i wanted to tell everybody i was
the guy going something's not right here
and it seems odd to me that they have to
drug him before he goes on stage or
whatever it is that they do to him or
that he had to keep going to bed at 2
p.m and we put a lid on everything at 3
p.m and blah blah blah blah blah so they
the rats on the ship they're going to
bolt when they realize that the ship is
sinking right they're going to get on
the life rafts um but this is a problem
this is a problem that we just don't do
these things honestly in real time no
pun intended related to the mars segment
before it's like we can all see things
but the airlock on the system doesn't
let us all talk about it at the same
time and maybe that was all okay
for many many years but in the time of
the internet and social media
it doesn't kind of work too many of us
are realizing the truth and what do you
do with all that
to that point on nbc's meet the press
which is basically a democrat program
chuck todd is obviously a democrat okay
obviously
even on nbc
even chuck todd is having to slightly
address some of this stuff that's how
bad it's gotten that's how how much
bludgeoning there is in this situation
take a look new nbc news poll suggests
mr biden doesn't need a reset because
he's lost his identity a bit he's no
longer seen as competent and effective
he's no longer seen as a good
commander-in-chief or perhaps most
damaging as easygoing and likable in
fact just five percent of adults say mr
biden has performed better than expected
as president one of the many lowest
firsts and fewests in our poll
and as we kick off our meet the midterms
coverage heading into november the nbc
news political unit developed what we're
calling a midterm meter it's based on
previous election cycles it's basically
three poll numbers you need to know best
i'm going to start with the perhaps the
most important number to understand
the direction of the midterms it's job
approval here the president's job
approval rating sitting at 43 percent if
you look at history history shows that
kind of presidential approval rating
leads to a shellacking for the party in
power how about the mood of the nation
well let me show you this right now our
wrong track nation's on the wrong track
number sitting at 72 percent second poll
in a row where we've been over 70 that's
only the third time in our polls history
over 30 years we've had two tracks that
uh were that off that again would put
you in shellacking territory for the
party in power
okay so when chuck todd at msmb or
nbc it's all the same [ __ ] but at nbc
is ringing the alarm right when he's
sounding the bell when he's screaming
about all this stuff
now look we know
that in the midterm elections usually
the incumbent president's party gets
whacked right it's just what happens it
happened to obama it happened to clinton
before that it happens bush it happened
to trump like the people are just like
oh this guy isn't so great or not as
great as we thought he was going to be
so like the other guys come in and it's
always easier to be more robust in your
attacks and everything else when you're
not the party that's in charge in
essence so things are obviously tracking
really well for the republicans and in
this case it's not just because biden's
a disaster it's because republican
states are being run better at the
moment there's something called policing
you know there's something called
election integrity there's something
called you know allowing people to go to
work and not lock everybody down and not
forcing them to be injected like there's
a lot of stuff happening right now but
what chuck todd is doing there is he's
warning biden basically because he
realizes how bad it is so that that's
good now again chuck is he's a democrat
obviously he's pretending right he's
pretending to be this impartial thing
but what he really wants to happen which
is why he's doing the segment is biden
to fix this thing not because he's he's
just an american who would want things
to be better but he doesn't want his
guys to lose power but i don't even want
to make this about chuck todd's too
specifically the point is
that to link this entire show together
if i had a thread through this entire
show
we all see something ain't right we all
see something right sometimes we don't
all see it at the exact same time
but now i think it's our job
to
help the people who aren't seeing it as
clearly as us get to that conclusion
and that is not to say you got to run
around with a republican pin of an
elephant on your lapel i do not consider
myself a republican believing in a set
of ideas is separate than being part of
a political party i have differences of
opinion
with mainstream republicans i consider
myself begrudgingly pro-choice you you
guys know all this stuff there are some
in the conservative movement who are not
happy about my marriage i accept all of
these things
i have found these people to be open to
debate
and care about ideas and know why they
believe what they believe and there's
nothing left on the other side so my
message barry weiss and bill maher if
you're watching this is let's talk about
it let's talk about it as a matter of
fact i won't put ads on the show or i'll
donate whatever we make to any charity
of your choice
but otherwise
otherwise i gotta keep going after you
right like i gotta not going after you
because i think you're bad people
but at some point
it's a problem it's a problem if you're
stopping a whole slew potentially
millions and millions of other people
from making the right choice if you know
what is real and what is true and you
just won't do something because you
don't you still want to be invited to
nice parties or bill maher i don't want
to live in florida and you still want to
live in beverly hills and do all that
well then it's a
problem
so
a couple comments from the locals
community and then uh i think i'm gonna
feel like i need to like shower or
something after this one uh coach rob
says jesus dave rubin it's monday
morning you got me all wound up please
end with clyde and what a great thing
david janet made for dinner last night
well we don't have any of our stuff so
we're literally working off one frying
pan and one pot so it's been a lot of
pasta uh last night we had friends over
and we just we ordered in some pizza uh
but clyde is doing great michael frankie
by the way bought him a uh alligator
today so clyde's been chewing on an
alligator i just posted a picture over
there on the twitter uh hope says uh way
to use the f-bomb perfecto
sometimes it just it's in you you know
what i mean it's sitting in you and you
don't want to say it because you don't
want them to hurt you in the algorithm
but you must say it because otherwise
you'll just explode and that's what
happened there
nt says biden's poll numbers will only
continue to continue to go down this is
the most inept corrupt incompetent
administration we've ever seen ever
yes you are correct uh guys part one of
my interview with marco rubio it's up
right now on the uh on the youtube or is
it coming out later today it'll be out
later today soon part one of my
interview with marco rubio uh i believe
it's up on vocals already the full
interview yes it is up on local during
the full interview we did about an hour
he is my senator from the great and free
state of florida we figured it would be
appropriate that my first interview here
in florida should be with either rubio
or desantis we're working on the
desantis situation part one will be up
on youtube shortly the full episode is
already up ad free over at
reubenreport.locals.com and i will be on
charlie kirk's show uh later today
and lara trump's show the right view
later today i had a busy day and i got
to get back to ikea all right i hope you
enjoy the show everybody do me a favor
again make sure you're subscribed and
all of that stuff and uh and i suppose
think about what i said and do you agree
do you disagree and what are you gonna
do about it let me know